britain has its 56th prime minister liz
trust the longest serving member of the
cabinet has succeeded boris johnson in a
contest that few foresaw just a few
months ago liz trust outwitted her
political foes and her political friends
to assume this job uh becoming prime
minister up in balmoral in the last few
minutes taking on an in-trade perhaps
bigger than any prime minister maybe
since margaret thatcher maybe since the
second world war
with conflict and strife abroad
challenges at home
as we're at this perilous point with the
british economy within hours she has to
form a new government that her allies
say will mark a radical departure even
from the work of boris johnson and then
within days she's got to set out a bold
and far-reaching plan that will see her
help households all across the country
deal with this phenomenal rise in the
basic cost of living with the sharp
increase in energy costs and what a
contrast it's going to be to just a few
days ago those weeks of the summer the
long summer when boris johnson referred
to himself in his farewell speech there
is a as a booster that comes back to
earth you could use another space
analogy and say he's being like a like a
satellite in space orbiting pointlessly
that we lost contact with the government
has been doing nothing now it's going to
be all over as much as it can for the
last seven weeks nobody would deny that
effectively the british government has
been on hold where the conservative
party chose a successor to boris johnson
but if you were being a bit more honest
dermot you would actually say that
because of the scandal that has engulfed
boris johnson's premiership across the
final months that has not been a clean
single focus of prime minister
for the prime minister because of the
multiple challenges remember we spent
months talking about parties we spent
months talking about the conduct of
boris johnson and those around him so it
would be wrong just to say that there
has been distraction in the last few
weeks there have been months and months
of uh turmoil in the heart of government
that has acted as a distraction in a
parliament that has seen
i mean really some of the most
far-reaching events of our lifetime uh
with a pandemic
dealing with the aftermath of brexit the
leaving of the single market and the
customs union so huge administrative as
well as political challenges uh and then
more recently the far-reaching
consequences
of the war in ukraine which is having a
which is causing a blight both on
households and for businesses already uh
having to come to terms with so many of
those challenges that's why there has
been an accumulation of problems uh now
all landing uh on liz truss's in tray
she will be back in a few hours time
here for the first time to walk in
through that door as prime minister
giving us a speech that will set out the
direction of travel that would put
finding growth getting rid of that
anemic uh
uh economic improvement that uh she
thinks has been at the root of british
problems for the last 20 years as she
will put finding that at the heart of
her mission but first she's got to deal
with energy bills